i have taught ap physics classes for the
last seven years ap physics 1 ap physics
b back in the day and ap physics c now i
try to make my lessons personable
relate to the student
offer them real life examples where
things happen
but also focus on instead of a bunch of
little memorization facts like what's
the big idea that helps you figure out
all these different situations for like
allows you to be more of a robust
problem solver so we're focusing on the
big core ideas of of
our subject being physics
and i think you'll find that across all
the different
ap content subjects we are finely tuned
to what the ap
exam is going to be like directly
and we are building in videos
for instructions specific to that
and also we have practice exercises that
i'm really excited about that you can
assign it to students and there's hints
and there's feedback why a certain
problem is wrong and why a certain
problem is right and then like it shows
you the solution path of how you would
get to the solution so when you assign a
student a problem
they don't have to wait a whole 24 hours
until they get back to class they can
get it wrong fail early
try another one fail often and do a
couple times on that and i actually
think my students might actually do more
home like homework because they're
getting
instant feedback on the process rather
than just trying a couple and getting
stuck and like i'm frustrated i'm out of
here
they can like really
get in the seat and stay in there
because they're getting instant feedback
and help as they're working through
problems i think that's going to be
really powerful